pour notre petit caux varela on va
commencer un 13h15 aujourd'hui je vais
attendre que vous arriviez
tranquillement en attendant j'ai concédé
partie de grand maître
je vais faire semblant de regarder je
les connais pas et en israël
michael owen a déjà quelques personnes
qui sont inscrites en amont on va jouer
en 3 + 2 d'ailleurs vous me dire les
cadres ce que vous préférez
et si nous avons envie pour la semaine
prochaine qu'on fasse des petites
variantes d'une cabine où vous avez
testé le roi de la colline du crédit à
ouges on peut faire un petit peu de tout
je peux aussi jouer et distribuer
généreusement mais point l'eau s'ils la
désirent amateurs salut au grand maître
gims n'a déjà une flopée d'habitués de
ses arénas du midi qui sont inscrits
manu guignard toujours au rendez vous
salle hustache iec
comment mathieu
on a
quand ça gagne star classe et 2500 pour
l'instant on verra s'ils terminent
tournera plus ou moins de miel ce sera
la petite surprise peut-être l'homme à
abattre cet appareil contre lille car
potentiel à iasi à fond et ouais ça peut
être un peu la distribution
surtout quand on quand on stream j'ai
pas trop l'habitude encore de commenter
mais pas si en parlons donc les quelques
fous que j'ai essayé les libérations
points à chaque fois mais pour changer
je peux jouer aussi un petit peu
salut l'artiste j'avoue m'être le lien
quand même si vous avez pas le tournoi
elle voit marcy psycho d'inscrits aussi
grecques béchec les joueurs qui sont là
tous les jours z comme fidèle à ce
rendez vous vinci qui l'a donc le
château s'il vous avez regardé un petit
peu mais hier le fameux magnus contre
nac affirme jade ig
vous avez suivi qu'avez fabre pour les
jeunes ça lui serve à lulu neo et you
pas trop déçu convient pas aujourd'hui
celle qu'il a passé un très bon moment
et hier pour ceux qui étaient là avec
marie clairet streamera d'ailleurs la
semaine prochaine ça du bief volailles
ont la frite à la concurrence
aujourd'hui c'est toujours moi je te
vois inscrire le chiot qui a déjà gagné
cette arène plusieurs fois le peu de
cyrus sympathisants à poutine double
creux chou foule battre ou pas le
laisser gagner
salut à tous prix de la cabine
maintenant à part ce petit caux puis
encore plein boom qui va s'inscrire au
contraire voient ça comme une occasion
de le faire et belle perf l'a déjà eu en
à rennes 1 2 victoires avec 1000 pour l
od car j'en ai commenté
donc tout est possible
salut art il
je peux dire à effet c'est l'association
française de rubik's cube ok je
l'ignorais du coup tu as un pro du
rubik's cube speed shopping à marcy qui
part dans la poésie peut être l'avez
vous êtes d'ailleurs dans le chat
s'était qui s'était pas frank zappa
justement quel est un site un blog de
huy écrivait de la poésie je ne m'abuse
eux si je ne m'abuse bat sébastien joie
qui nous fait l'honneur de sa présence
un maître international
vous connaissez bien habitués de la
chaîne qui va se frotter un as a gangsta
françois-xavier pots-de-vin pour ceux
qui le connaissent dans le milieu
échiquéen le petit nathan rousse qui est
présent et puis bien sûr modèle volaille
toujours là ok donc ça
je connais pas du tout le rubik's cube
j'imagine que effectivement que vous
n'avez des tournois comment ça marche
que nous expliquer un petit peu speed
cabine parce que j'ai du mal à voir par
exemple comment pour y organiser des
trucs par équipe ou alors ça peut être
comme aux échecs
le numéro en complet numéro un le plus
rapide de chaque club qui s'affrontent
et ainsi de suite
c'est uniquement individuelle il s'agit
plutôt d'un système de lots ou pas wen
et 6 passes en moins de 10 secondes
c'est impressionnant il ya des tours de
magie sympa aussi avec le tube va pas
mal de vidéos amusantes mais la seule
fois j'ai essayé j'ai vite été rachetés
de rubik's cube d'eau que c'est pas pour
moi je crois ça demande trop de patience
stérile
nomidia n'a pas d'adversaire quoi à part
soi même c'est plus frustrant bon nombre
auquel on fait des classes pour mondiaux
c'est pas le mélo parce que pas de
face-à-face d'accord et est ce qu'il
existe des professionnels des tout
meilleurs mondiaux bambi ou pas ça du
perceval et karadoc et toute la team k
plate salut crise mais elle a fait douze
secondes sur le glacier waouh c'est
impressionnant les siennes mais la
position des parts attribués ou est ce
que ces gens comme richard vandomme où
il ya plusieurs je sais pas comment ça
marche au fait tu me rends pas trop
compte d'une s'imagine commence avec la
même position de départ parce que selon
à quel point les clubs sont des faits
s'était plus ou moins facile
ça commence pour cette ville une bombe à
content si c'est un univers dans lequel
les possibles au moins pour les tous
meilleurs de 400 euros par mois plus les
déplacements coupe mpm auquel on s'est
regardé quand même plus vraiment une
passion qui peut mettre un peu de beurre
dans les épinards pour les meilleurs des
difficiles
bon plus c'est juste la mémoire tu
penses cris 6 mais là je passais speed
cabine peut nous confirmer
il ya la dextérité quand même un petit
peu qui doit entrer en ligne de compte
j'imagine salue le gaffeur bêcher et oui
il y aura un maximum cet aprem aussi
contraint à annuler à tort maxime qui
doit de grand favori quand je pense aux
rapides quand même surtout sur sa lancée
des candidats je sais que kg des femmes
jetteront un oeil et commenteront un peu
de temps en temps parallèlement aux
jeunes si le serveur un piège comme les
laisse tranquilles et cameron allait
pour l'autre match mais ça peut être
rigolo si carla n'est pas là pour le
coup elle donne pas chère forcément de
la peau de caruana salut ma veille
développeurs oui exactement
les volcans ok donc ce qui fait vraiment
la différence au niveau c'est la
dextérité du coup tu penses tout le
monde à mémoriser tous les bruits c'est
quoi
vous faites gymnastique doit coucher
comment ça se passe
saiem l'autre se passe en 18 algorithmes
waouh ça peut être un bon exercice à 10
pour les échecs 1 peut-être juste de
mémoire simplement pour les ouvertures
vous trouvez des points à mon avis entre
les deux disciplines a toujours pour
l'instant top 4 dans ce cas ça n'a pas
changé mais racisme bousculé par les
outsiders
je vois dans l'agglo qui seront là aussi
car h 38 n'a toujours pas pu jouer nice
et le calage commenté avec le début sera
l'objectif de la journée
kevin base je passe et a suivi un peu
dernièrement mais on tourne pas mal mais
aussi marie aïe aïe aïe alibi et bien
sûr a commenté six arènes du midi salut
qu'à kalach et kelvin distribuera à 16h
justement avec fabre les jeunes de
l'équipe de france ça a commencé hier
j'avais pu suivre un petit peu sa part
les pizzas mouettes et un petit peu
d'échecs oscille entre deux bacs
serveurs
laquelle a vraiment intéressant speed
cabine par rapport aux autres casse tête
parce que là ils étaient quand même sur
le tard plutôt le rubik's cube est ce
que pareil il ya des liens vous
entraînez russie et a priori j'ai pas
faire le tournoi donc je vais vous
commentez et peut-être demain je jouerai
est d'ailleurs assez nombreuses dit moi
un petit peu demain s'il a envie de
faire une autre variante par exemple en
affichant pour dames
ou est ce que vous voulez rester dans
classique ou un crazy house on apprend
la colline d'ailleurs ou un autre truc
qui existe
j'ai donc en repérer random nous dit aqa
lâche pas c'est sûr que j'imagine ça moi
profond que les échecs à voir où tout
cas points de richesse a priori paraît
difficilement égalable devrait faire
venir un pompier poupe assez dépouillé
poupe la leur doit un plateau de rêve
fischer dams et les échecs 960 le
gaffeur bgc celui où on tire au sort la
position de départ et vu qu'il ya une
version 60 positions possibles d'où le
bond à bild
1500 saqqara mon grand écart doit être
super super souris dont à cette bonne
question ça devrait me disent qu est ce
que ça se fait à la blague parce que
j'ai rappelé au pied que les doigts qui
travaillent ton cerveau a pas besoin de
voir ces pages comme les grands maîtres
qui regardent au plafond à chaque fois
pas que d'ailleurs vous êtes plutôt
chaud sur les 960 donc je pense que
demain partira dessus ça a l'air de vous
motiver
ça change un peu ça peut aussi
équilibrer les fins moi j'adore je
jouais je jouerai avec vous je pense
pour me frotter à l'élite déclaré naji
midi on va commencer dans une minute
avec un petit chèque pour l'instant ça
gangsta entre sébastien joie il suffira
pour commencer et puis réussit on
s'intéressera pour 17 points 9 secondes
donc sa proie plus gros cubes de compris
et oui le gaffeur beges avait là aussi
on tp lalalalalalalalala qui a rejoint
le club des favoris ben
aujourd'hui pleut ça par l'afei perbos
toute la semaine je suis presque heureux
qu'il pleuve toute façon moi je peux pas
vraiment profité et comme ça je subis
par mes voisins en train de bronzer mais
d'un magasin de jardin donc mon côté
très aigrie se réjouit de la plus à huy
à la pac ok j'avais raté c'est vraiment
plus sur la table
c'est la srf on peut le dire en bus pour
arriver où a commencé puisqu'on a
commencé non si donc j'ai tout de suite
m'intéressait
j'ai raté le tout début donc ça gangsta
ème place et 2500 ici vous n'avez 2713
qui hier on sait pas comment ça va se
terminer mais pour lui qu affrontent la
fronde ce thème si le joueur qui joue
très vite d'être encore dans la théorie
moi je vous avoue que du moins en
théorie si je suis débat ses débuts des
canaries oui entre kcr fouet deux sagas
distincts qui pense la première est en
train de directement se voir greffer
l'étiquette de plâtrerie ici là ces
pièces sur la première rangée avec les
blancs est apparue ultra ambitieux
jamais à se dire et loire c'est petit
waroquet d un peu plus d espace à terme
d'une structure d'options plus saine
voilà l'ouverture d'un colloque mais
permet aussi quand même d'attaquer un
petit peu baissé mais c'est pas
dramatique
puis s'il a égalisé voire plus sans ce
problème mais aussi les pièces qui
peuvent être un peu bracket sur le roi
pourquoi pas ça peut donner des idées
la b6 et sa règle tous les problèmes sur
la colonne b alain clément n'a jamais
envie de manger le cas parce qu'on se
retrouve avec un îlot de pions très très
faible joue ses cartes mais se retrouver
quand même un cavalier ici qui en mur et
par ses propres pièces stratégiquement
la proche des blancs semblent un peu
douteuse en fait parce que d'abord il
espère uniquement que les doigts après
dans des trois pour les libérer or va ce
n est pas du tout obligé de prendre des
3 au contraire ils arrivent à maintenir
l'attention l'a peut-être juste un petit
coup tours ebitda même si cela marche
qu'à douala tour éviter jouer la
meilleure le placement de cette pièce il
est très bien ici la clé noir alors
tombée sans que ça c'est plutôt
ingénieux pourquoi pas s'il doit ramener
7,3 en jeu sauf qu'elle va quand même
bouquet de cases intéressante
j'ai peur que ça ressemble plus à un
coup d'épée dans l'eau qu'autre chose
alors peut-être si elle jouait des
quatre avec les plans simplon et f3 il
faudra libérer les problèmes sur la
colonne peu quand même
alors oui je sais ça que ça gangsta je
pense qu'il a envie de suivre par des
quatre ensuite comme fermer le centre
d'hamsik là c'est blonde empêche
contrôle parfaitement la case j'aime de
moins en moins la position des blancs
d'ouverture ces quelques balles passées
ici le garder je sais que la première
c'est toujours mal c'est pas grave y'a
pas de
donc ça continue double attaque 17
pourquoi pas mais je sais pas j'ai un
peu peur pour ce roi parfois avec des
dames h4 le camion arrivant des quatre
pointes de se retrouver faible aussi
parfois
après les changements du cep qui choisit
la proche la plus en plus sûr ici il ya
certainement raison il était obligé de
sacrifier le pion bessède on m'a juste
reprendre le 4 et finalement la position
des noirs il sera simplement derrière
parce qu'ayant meilleure structure deux
pions des pièces plus active avec les
blancs ou ici fossiles de limete
laquelle devait changer des pièces au
maximum et peut-être de petites mains se
battre pour la bulle mais encore du
travail pour ça le chemin est long ici
pour sagan est stable et il veut se
faire un petit peu ma c'est quand même
c'est pas le genre de passage dont on en
dit surtout par les temps qui courent
alors ces trois essais de se faire un
chemin pour son cavalier l'avant poste
ce qui d'emblée même pas un très bien
fragile
la page web j'ai dû me g3 un peu troué
sur carte blanche
heureusement les noirs du foot
qu'hazebrouck meas cavaliers qui peut
venir devenir dangereux les tours
provoque de trois parfois ainsi qu'ils
peuvent traîner
attention ici on accueille g5
c'est une spécialité saga nice nice il a
fait d'avoir été dominé stratégiquement
dans cette partie il s'en sort par une
pirouette tactique celle qui joue un
petit peu vite il a triplé dans la
colonne 2 apparaissait très naturelle et
les blonds finalement qu'il ne sait pas
grand chose de plus
un parfait geek cette dame elle menace
de manger achètent ou que la tour e 4
s'est perdu à l'essai de contre attaquer
on s'en prenant à la tour des cinq ici
mais s'il suffit à priori si je rate
rien de juste bouger cette tour avec les
blancs et derrière on pour encaisser à
la qualité
à l'âge où est tombé 3 voilà il n'y a
pas de défense
évidemment c'est la tour bouge la dame
prend achète ce vide damache rythme at
donc la partie qui s'est retournée
vraiment sûr tactique qui sort un peu de
nulle part cette dame mais en vain mot
j'ai un rôle inattendu elle kachine
qu'un problème de lag je sais pas si les
autres peuvent le confirmer ou non et
oui ma connexion comme d'habitude ne
sais pas d'autres matches difficiles
j'ai pas trop un dos à dos le matin et s
m je comprends c'est le matin pour moi
aussi donc je suis compatissant cette
partie qui s'est terminée par une
nouvelle tactique un double échec et
celle qui perd des cavaliers donc on
peut au passage de temps c'en était trop
qu'il abandonnait ses dommages où ils
avaient vraiment dominé plutôt la
position va essayer de trouver une autre
partie alors va peut-être pas regarder
sceptre de suite ce serait un petit peu
tombé sur ticket mal sic et man
peut-être à d'autres pseudos de pukki
poupe qui cède la fronde sont beaucoup
ou à voir si la force et en lui pour
l'instant il a perdu une pièce va
suspendre une boule de feu semble
beaucoup ça s'est mal passé qu'est ce
qui s'est passé va vérifier quand même
il s'est fait clouer là c'est l'accident
la couverture donc partie qui s'annonce
compliqué pour lui ok lamche ce jour et
j'espère que ça va se stabiliser à trop
de prise sur ma connexion jusque aussi
un bad buzz et ça marchait plutôt bien
alors
sangoku de shiro mode en votes caritatif
ici tippett je pense que va pouvoir le
laisser conclure cette partie
tranquillement parce que malheureusement
c'est pas un mec hyper à gagner du poids
il mange tout avec une dame d'une tour
de plus on peut faire confiance à sa
technique on essaie de trouver une
partie un peu plus serré original
rigolotes sur la première partie
d'ailleurs ces deux joueurs contre
kalach et lynch est ce là trois pions
contre une tour le problème ici c'est
que bien sûr les pions noirs ne vont pas
dans ce sens là ils vont par là elle y
trouve un barrage devant eux
normalement quand 23 devant les pions
même s'ils sont liés comme ça y'a pas de
problème pour en rajouter un quatrième
ça devrait être encore maîtrisable c'est
peut-être un peu plus techniques comme
mais c'est vraiment ça gagne assez
facilement pour les plans il suffit de
prendre les gaz derrière on va chasser
droit et ont glissé les plombs point par
wild cat devrait normalement gagner
facilement y aura plus de coups les
pions travaille pas très bien ensemble
issia sur g5 on va juste manger il va
sûrement essayer hkd voilà est ici un
peu tout qui va gagner parce qu'à un
moment donné quand on sera obligé de
jouer g5y on pourra manger être cinq
on va se retrouver en zigzag n'aura que
des mauvais coups suffit d'attendre avec
la tour de vous d'être prêt à passer
derrière ça ça marche aussi jestin croit
propres gk ça peut être un peu dangereux
ceci dit quand même on perd le tempo et
ne tienne sur la tour mais
je pense que tout est sous contrôle
alors ma mais pour ce qui est du top 12
et des autres divisions bah justement
cette semaine on a reçu des mails de
présidents de clubs nous envoyer des
mails pour leur dire que que la décision
est prise bien tout bientôt et ils nous
ont consultés en fait c'est à dire que
ce n'est pas la fédé qui va imposer son
truc chaque précédent un peu donne son
avis mais on a pas vraiment sûr pour
l'instant j'ai l'impression d'être plus
une annulation de la saison et on
reprendrait avec les mêmes l'an prochain
à zéro les mêmes étiez dans les mêmes
divisions votre pendant ce temps un
comme prévu le travail a été fait par la
tour et le roi
[Musique]
l'autre solution serait de faire monter
par exemple les clubs faire monter les
claques qui sont en tête à ce moment là
mais bon ça entraînerait quand même
certaines certaine injustice par rapport
au calendrier voilà on va essayer de
finir la saison à l'arrachement
supprimant des dates à la décision n'est
pas arrêtée du cas je crois dans ce
genre de situation il y aura toujours
des clubs qui seront plus ou moins lésés
quelle que soit la décision
malheureusement salut you can't make my
way on a vu ça pour le rugby qui l
aiment partager l'info derrière il y
avait un article sur l'équipe j'avais
partagé ça sur la page facebook de
duchess com fr il est très heureux où je
bikic mais du coup ces gamins très
sûrement
il doit bien jouer à 2000 je pense pour
le cndd simultané pour faire du groupe
maxime j'ai pas regardé
à parti par contre dans des tailles juge
lui la position finale mais on sentait
que c'était un joueur d'échecs voi le
mec gênant c'est une partie de notre ami
elle gang contre bruno salut guillaume
est ici bush belgique c'est un joueur de
tennis croix et la carte chic a pris sa
retraite
maintenant qui était coach dernièrement
il a entré ce qui l'a entraîné fédéral
on ne vit pas de quadrille pas duré très
longtemps
je crois donc c'était roger aux
personnes coincées ça donne au joueur
très offensif plutôt moche bikic gros
serveur très grand le crâne rasé lui
sans l'enchaîner les ace au mental un
petit peu instable il entraîne encore eu
d'erreur il a pris un peu de distance
non il a fallu qu'on traîne des lois
dans une semaine avec maman de maxime
qui affrontait je crois que c'est une
vingtaine de joueurs même temps c'était
25 quelque chose comme ça et maxime
avait dû lâcher 3 nuls et perdu parti et
il y avait des forges voir quand même
enfin ce but que nous nous il n'est pas
titrait vous savez même pas qu'ils
jouent aux échecs en compétition a
priori en amateur un donateur très
éclairé alors un peu sous coke est assez
intéressante une égalité matérielle ou
moins qu'il ya un blocus au fait qui est
pas forcément qui est assez atypique en
tout cas devant ses deux tours comme ça
stopper la marche des pions blancs
si jamais avec les blancs on arrive à
genève cinq ans sera certainement
gagnant parce qu'ensuite de pinard et
table mais s'ils sont bien bloqué le roi
noir et en sécurité
roy blot semble un peu plus friable nous
apparaît difficile de progresser pour
les blancs et les noirs on a ainsi
l'impression qu'ils sont obligés
d'attendre en fait c'est un petit peu le
statu quo de joueurs qui peuvent se
regarder dans les yeux et attendant que
le premier craque sous la pression et
dans ce genre de position c'est souvent
le premier qui prend une décision qui
joue
le gain qui va perdre et si typiquement
c'est elle qui vient de se passer avec
eux jusqu'à un coup très risqué pour
casser cette statue qu il ya derrière
maintenant voilà cf4 qui va tomber
la position de l gones qui parle peu
nombreux ici de ne pas chère la peau
dure aux noirs durable ans je pense
qu'un match devrait arriver que ces
retards des gens voient pas pour
l'instant je le tour j'ai trois pour
essayer de se sauver
bien sûr ne pas manger de ce qu'il y
aurait une petite fourchette à yaya
toure g4 qui sauvent quand même après la
reprise et avec l'option n'arrivera à
clouer à accourir plongé trois tonnes
d'armes a potentiellement sécurité j'ai
cru à la catastrophe à baal catchy salut
pierrot ouais pourquoi pas aussi le tard
et quand même des mêmes velde a un peu
de sa superbe potentiel
tu as à peu près 20 fois plus de temps
pour réfléchir à chaque coup déjà c'est
quand même une aide puis surtout en
terme de concentration hockey je pensais
que roger l'état en autodidacte en ce
moment avec juste juste mire car pour
l'accompagner mais ces risques dans les
tribunes il est encore là des fois le
pic dans les tribunes verra l'année
prochaine du coup peut-être enfin roland
garros en hangar où ce qui a été reporté
en septembre
si vous avez suivi mais je sais pas si
ça va tenir cette histoire un peu la
surprise par regarder roland garros
pendant que les gens réalisent leur bac
blanc fera bizarre je pose c'est un peu
dur pour cette génération ne pas avoir
ce moment privilégié de rater son pack à
cause de roland garros face à apt trois
des candidats très bons préparateurs de
maxime sinon bah on voit que breno il
abrogeait des pions des débats à l'aris
il a attendu que les blancs fasse un
truc est un petit peu auto détruit leurs
positions
attention parce que là je viens de dire
qu'il était malade
bien sûr il perd la partie d'instantanés
mans c'est la malédiction de poissard de
streamer elle est juste faire attention
à ce droit à sa paire la dame le
problème c'est qu'ici
après avoir perdu la table à tout risque
d'attendre gourdon j'ai aussi parce
qu'elle est relativement éloigné du roi
d'un provincial c'est le seul coup le
roi n'a pas de casque dont il ya match
et du coup elles gang qui a peu dans le
pire des cas manquer c'est tout les
plombs y'a pas de chèque a priori qu'il
gagne mais pourquoi pas donc encore une
fois ça se retourne juste sur une petite
tactique sur le lien à globe trotter et
ouais on a tous les tournois de l'été a
priori qui sont annulés à voile a été
annulée comme gros tournois classiques
ceux qu'ont l'habitude du circuit
échiquéen je sépare mais je suppose
qu'ils sont tous plus ou moins adulé
même si le confinement élevé
progressivement d'un rassemblement de
masse
l'été arrive bientôt ce sera peut-être
pas la meilleure des choses je sais pas
sept jours attirent sera peut-être du
cas par cas
j'ai pas eu d'abandon qui s'est baladé
comme ph
j'ai raté un truc awingu là ils vendent
des huit échecs
tu aurais pu passer les vous avez l'oeil
dans le chatt laissait rien passer vous
du coup après pourrait même dans ce
genre de situation c'est qu'il ya mille
échec d'affilée du coup fait même plus
trop ghafoor mais la dame notre
adversaire aussi nous fait confiance il
a dû lâcher sa souris trop tôt et s'en
rendre compte
juste au dernier moment ceci dit
pourquoi le faire attention avec les
blancs parce que la technique de la
ligue ang
laisse un petit peu à désirer mais voilà
ça y avait eu 2 c'est bon il s'en sort
c'est comme des petites frayeurs
outre la daps gratuite bien sûr nous a
fait un petit peu peur et ils y accèdent
partie à rebondissements
on va voir qu'à bmx aux contres lune et
au bon ça s'est passé le début puisqu'on
dirait un classique ici ouverture verne
avec les noirs j'avance vite pour
revient à partie et l'acte de générosité
a été scellée au 10e coup ici par
l'union malheureusement sur canal 4 oui
plus jouer dams et 7
c'est vraiment à sa portée ici c'est un
peu dommage les partis au machrek il
peut oublier son bout des six où le
cavalier un value ainsi qu'à l'allier
ont décidé vraiment c'est la pieuvre la
pieuvre bis ça une très dure pour lui si
on va voir comment gab et finit le
travail
il pourra certainement gp7a on a vu
aussi avec les noirs et se dit bouba
foutu pour foutu je mets toutes mes
pièces sur le roi je vais essayer de
tout ballon et c'est pourquoi pas les
raisons de ciel se battre un vidéo toute
façon et we cannot masqué j'ai bien
parlé du tournoi d'avoir tout à l'heure
qui je crois a été annulée me semble
avoir vu l'info je sais plus trop quand
ni où j'ai lu ça quelque part
à confirmer mais un l'a priori oui
la mauvaise un bouc là-bas - a déjà fait
le tournoi du cougaing pas de masquer ou
pas ce cas là c'est vraiment un gros
événement pas des petits poèmes gleam
quelques années c'est quand même super
sympa avec plein d'activités organisées
toujours en parallèle les tours de vis
par équipes de scrabble d'un peu tous
les sports très saint valentin d'avoine
lui faire deux fois
s'il a deux pièces de plus maintenant
avec les avec les blancs c'est très
compliqué pour lui n'est autre sens à
retirer s'il n'y a pas trop de pièces
pour attaquer il n'y a même pas de dette
bat vraiment là le plus simple que vous
avez un gros avantage matériel je vous
conseille ne cherchez pas à faire trop
compliqué fait souvent défaut c'est
souvent comme ça que les parties peuvent
sur autour des justes et changer les
pièces pour à l'arrivée rester avec vous
ou plus un peu plus de allez petit coup
prophylactique aussi c'est toujours bien
on évite des maths du couloir sait
jamais ce qui peut se passer d âge 3 est
ce qu'il est c'est quand même une balle
de match qui lui monte des pièces lignot
parce qu'il ya des bonnes idées mais le
don du fonds en début de partie il lui
aurait été fatal
et oui c'est un bon tournoi et c'est
qu'il ya le cap d'agde aussi qu'un très
beau tournoi avec le trophée car pas
forge pas cet inconnu sabam et mais à
une époque assez trophée karpov qui
avait elle éduque arsène du die kacou
rare quand ils étaient jeunes bien sûr
avant d'être dans le top ou derniers
vendent chocques sicard à celle d'une
grosse grosse critique et il n'a jamais
fait b d'acs avoir un plein de jeunes
prodiges en tout cas il ya eu notamment
des finales
il vend chewbacca droit avec des gants
virois à tour de rôle qui était assez
épique
maintenant ils ont moins d'argent
compliqué donc du coup le tournoi un
petit peu vitrine accueille des joueurs
un peu moins connus mais ça reste quand
même très sympa non - edouard vii bakr
ont aussi souvent ce tournoi il ya la
tourache un qui a été oubliée par une
vidéo un petit peu nous la lune
aujourd'hui ça lui fait honneur à sa
gamme
trophée garde l'office genre à pied dans
général je sais pas cette année après le
câble d'accès en octobre donc ça devrait
pouvoir avoir lieu oui je dit paul garde
effectivement c'était chouette d'avoir
des événements comme ça en français
c'est un peu s'il va cogner l'été la
même année c'est dommage que ça se fasse
un petit peu moins alors il ya le grand
duché ce taux qui passe à paris 1 qui
devient du coup ça ça a été annulé aussi
et malheureusement là c'est pour le coup
avec les tout meilleurs mondiaux
la raison il force d'échangés d'arbres
qui s'il uneo qui pourrait abandonner
avec une tour en fut un cavalier de moi
on va s'arrêter là pour cette partie
c'est de se lancer dans quelque chose de
plus chaud alors là qishan abdel contre
jjj que j'ai déjà vu assez souvent aussi
eu l'occasion de commentaires sous
parties l'ouverture d'une espèce de pire
que peut-être à la position alors à
s'équilibraient bonsoir aeternam
peut-être tué le soir dans dans la
grande et tu as tout déphasé un tel
terme pardon je sais que je prononce pas
l'anglais finalement j'aurais fait le
lien se faire autant c'est des gens qui
vont s'inscrire sait-on jamais alors que
d'autres cette position les doigts
je vis de la colonne c'est le pion c'est
pour être une faiblesse sauf que l'on a
le foot est roi qui fait un bon rôle de
défenseur à défaut d'avoir l'acte i
parce que souhaitable pour l'instant
sciences pures des 5
c'est pas une pièce très intéressante
ici pour les plans des cavaliers pour
hassen pas traîné à bath et donc plus
souvent on va essayer de le réorienter
plus la caf et voir si un jour en
échangeant la vie sinon c'est le genre
de position vous n'êtes pas si évident
de trouver un plan je trouve là des fois
on a décidé à battre 2 à 4 ensuite ciblé
le pion à cet enfer une faiblesse et
pourquoi pas se faire tout passé paix et
côté doit on est quand même solide et si
on va certainement mettre une tour dans
la colonne c'est un bon donnait le choix
est assez bref cette course catchy
sabouk est toujours utile on va forcer
ce fou à prendre une décision et pareil
va falloir essayer de replacer cette
pièce parce qu'il n'est pas dupe eux
quatre ils passaient sur 24 et les
tables des deux j'ai passé les deux
joueurs avaient vu qu'ils ont eu un peu
de chance
mt 2 sauver sauver la partie pour les
hommes parce qu'on veut pas prendre ce
cavalier l'atacama adverses vont pouvoir
reprendre notre d'aborder deux avec
notre cavalier donc le clac ne
fonctionnait pas même faire très
attention puisque le thème tactique
pourrait très bien se se renouveler sous
peu à judith c'est la légende c'est la
meilleure nageuse de tous les temps et
elle est partie pour être détrôné elle
est symbolique pas pas le gars pardon
jean béguin c'est une sacrée histoire
c'est un petit peu à l'image des soeurs
williams a obtenu leur père les a élevés
pour en faire des champions et à des
championnes pour les mêler aux garçons
c'est aussi pour ça outre
leur talent il est incroyable surtout
judith m'a quand même qu'elle a pu aller
si vos judith et même challenge est
parfois un peu kasparov
cela va faire partie des dix meilleurs
joueurs mondiaux mais malheureusement ça
reste une exception
oui femme qui est la meilleure joueuse
du monde actuel à l'éden pas
professionnel à s'enfoncer dans un échec
c'est pour vous dire la différence entre
amis maîtres phil bxl kraft c'est à dire
que pour devenir maître international
il faut en plus faire un certain nombre
de performances dans des tournois qui
sont qui doivent répondre à des critères
très précis est aussi potentiellement
une différence de l orme être fait c'est
à partir de 2300 mètres attention al
2004 et grand maître c'est 2500 avec des
performances encore plus difficile et le
bal il plus dure à franchir a priori
entre maîtres et grands maîtres votre
maître phil et maître international vont
mettre cette demande vraiment un travail
énorme
ouais continue ses études à wil fatale
fredo c'est ça
après c'était quelqu'un de surdoué
l'oaci donc elle réussit à peu près tout
ce qu'elle fait c'est des études
brillantes jeunes j'oubliais j'ai su qu
est ce qu elle faisait précisément la
stanford d'accord tu te rappelles de
coyron ce que ces débats de la finance
rien à voir la psychose je sais je sais
plus j'avais lu une interview d'alex est
intéressant d'ailleurs ça s'est évaporé
dans mon esprit il ya maxime vachier
lagrave qui a continué comme ses études
de base jusqu'à sépare alors qu'il était
déjà 2700 était là aussi tellement
talentueux qu'eux
ce qui pouvait passer ces années on
allons pas par concours est aussi
facilement cet examen
non c'était évident pour lui le calcul
dans toutes ses formes le calcul ça
reste une exception chez de chez les
joueurs la daps dowell quatre fois grand
maître anglais l'un des plus jeunes
grands maîtres aussi je crois dans les
quinze ans et quelques un petit prodige
qui n'est pas pro va pas loin de 2720
car nous allons au tour de 2007 sont
bien quand même très peu de 27 plus on
va dire qu'ils ne sont pas pour et
quelques-uns qui joue un peu trop beau
car ça arrive mais heureusement les
échecs sont là pour rattraper leurs
pertes en gambling alors on va en
prendre un peu cette partie quand même
entre entre qui jeta jjj qu'à l'heure de
gk monsieur viraux d'un oeil très bien
joué
la gratter un pion central d'un forces
tentent alors pour l'instant peut y
avoir la case des cinq un petit peu en
contre je si les plans et arrive à y
installer leurs cavaliers ça peu un
petit peu bloqué la progression de des
noirs vient de la chef 5 elle aussi b4
keith et robert mais je pense que valait
mieux de perdre b4 kf5 pour les noirs
c'est un peu dommage de ne pas avoir
défendu ce point ici un bon comme d'hab
m7 tout simplement bab el hara avait
l'air d'être l'abbaye alors certes les
blancs rattraper leurs déséquilibres
matériel mais ensuite ce qui était bien
ce qu'on pouvait jouer des 5
et là ça fait un peu peur quand même la
barre est en marche
alors parfois d'avoir les contrôles
avancés ça peut être une faiblesse mais
ici ils sont parfaitement soutenue par
les pièces droit et après des catch
pense que l'abolition a été écrasante
après on va me dire la partie ça s'est
passé ici de cavaliers pros lâche 3 jr
bad prix de beauté avec idées sur
j'éprouve 3 la dame 3,3 bien jouer mais
malheureusement la partie s'est terminée
je sais pas celle malheureusement pour
lui sur cayenne france 3 il y avait
cavaliers projet cet intermédiaire et
quand vous faites une tactique alors est
ce pas facile avec le plus de temps la
pendue vous toujours vérifiables un
point intermédiaire 1 d'échec le
derrière les fagots un coût qui
attaquent votre table ou une prise de
pièces qui peut casser complètement
votre combinaison et la typiquement il a
pris une pièce aux coûts intermédiaires
un accord encore une autre qu'à la fin
de la barre est haute
malheureusement pour lui chez n'importe
quoi je m'auto embrouilles et 6 passes
cavaliers pro 7 7
les progiciels ne marche pas ce que les
cas les problèmes deux échecs où je me
fais complètement sûr à cet acte barbare
jiji il a bien gagné un pion aux
battages ne verra si ce n'est pas
quelque chose doute pour le lait blanc
aurait pu bouger le four qu'est ce qui
se passe sur
pour elle et prendre le cavalier un f6
il y avait une envie la ddt avec fougue
et 6 bat c'est bien d'annoncer un an à
l'iran m6 mais c'était dans un autre
plus ce qui nous intéresse ici est fou
j'ai trois peut-être est-ce qu'il va
lire bien ouais ok on va faire comme si
j'avais regardé la tactique un
fonctionnel donc barreau jiji la
tactique a fonctionné
du coup j'ai même pas pu voir la fin il
a gagné autant hockey de toute façon il
avait quand même un bon piont empêche
donc il a très bien joué va relancer une
partie ou pas puisque la se termine pile
au bon j'arrive avec une défaite de manu
à qui je l'avais pas porter la poisse
depuis bien longtemps
alors là le gaffeur fou qu'a les blancs
n'ont qu'à les noirs parlement contre ma
terrain non j'ai perdu à jean [ __ ] de
la foule de la doudoune et tous les maux
qui se termine en août on talent une
tradition de sa capote basket
vous n'êtes plus profession du terminal
alors comment ça se passe pour le
gaffeur fou surtout début de l'art est
notre attitude c'est n'importe quoi
mais il a avoué la gagner j'ai la
scoumoune jeux démos ou une peut être
sympa je pense prendre une tournure
d'être douteuses mais c'est pas toi
lagaf arabe et j'ai tu n'es pas le
cafard fou ok autant pour moi ça fait
clown ou deux ça marche on peut on peut
autoriser les orthographes un peu un peu
différent il ya deux fois en crise c'est
pour moi un autre os du coup le gaffeur
fou et qui a mangé un fou va être très
très heureux ici à une perte de plus
quand ça se passait bien pour les blancs
qui ont voulu jouer un coup
intermédiaire fois cinq ici était
complètement réfuté finalement donc ce
n'est pas une bonne idée pour matt
malheureusement il va devoir lutter avec
sa pièce de monde ça s'annonce compliqué
gemini axel d'accord en marche
ici ici pour mater avoir je ne vois pas
de solution puisque options et 6
malheureusement il va tomber russie
c'est un petit peu ça tire larmes
espérer que la dame noire
bush pour faire une découverte de
meurtrières je voudrais que le gaffeur
fou voire extrêmement coopératif pour
que ça arrive vicié donc se battre avec
une pièce de mois surtout en k-way
kwajalein crémant c'est dur la pub 20
secondes en plus ma terreur voir le pion
à six qui tombe le gaffeur fou qui porte
mal son pseudo pour l'instant renault
tu veux faire plaisir à ton adversaire
relancé le suspense dans cette partie
n'hésite pas cavalier h3 échec ici pour
le beau jeu un peu de bol si mattera
cela est peut-être mourir autant noms
font du wpt tu le fais de gaffard
faisait bon respect éternel pour toi tu
restes mieux a fait cavalier h3b tu
perds ta chesnut de plus quoi or il le
fait c'est la déstabilise son adversaire
il va tomber
non ok là c'est la classe ces trucs
comme ça c'est vraiment en mode grand
seigneur ici innovation pour regard fou
on espère aussi bien quand même la
partie pour lui où il a très bien joué
jusque là donc j'ai confiance qu'il a
quand même ouvert le roi à versailles
plus que deux secondes vite fous ces
trois bien jouer ma terreur qui se bat
il a donné une seconde chance dans la
vie
il veut la saisir il a raison là il
devait y avoir un petit peu des réseaux
de chèques perpétuelle parfois 6 ou
disparaît alors ils échangent les dames
ok maintenant la finale avec la
tourtière autre en septième toute bonne
pour les blondes
elle est objective moi pas très galant
bien ce roi qui est coupée c'est
embêtant un but si la chasse est et bien
faire bouger des âmes est aussi en train
de se passer
55 secondes donc ça c'est une pression
constante
mais ces cavaliers h3 beau joueur ouais
bien s'avérer fatale puisque ma terreur
a depuis il laisse plus rien passer
il n'est pas vraiment un robot de
bouquets de jouer à ça tombe bien je
peux jouer vite tu peux jouer sur les 2
secondes et en finale deux tours je gère
ya pas de problème alors il a pris goût
à 5 c'est dommage quand même ce qui
pouvait vite mon gb 6 et maintenant on
se dirige vers un magnifique quatre
contre trois avec des tubes doublet doit
être objectivement mieux mais on sent
que tout peut se passer dans cette
partie gaffard fou comme juste pour la
beauté du suspense attention d'un achète
un peu décontenancé quand même et on
espère qu'ils voient moins sauver la
glissière méritent ils méritent
oui presque presque pas d'un très bon
oeil l'idée du siècle
attention piège si on prend les noms
vidal et la tour derrière
ok manger heureusement ça devrait se
terminer par ap cette partie mon g4 ici
à weedon ceux qui la donnent esprit
dutil devant normalement il ya deux
pions de plus donc je crains que
techniquement ce ne soit foutu on sait
jamais c'est encore pas si clair avec le
fait d'avoir peut-être un blocus les
blondes du mal dans certaines positions
particulières avec deux points de plus
en finale deux tours a peut être nulle
[Musique]
selon l'activité du roi adverse
sélection
et là malheureusement cette fenêtre de
roanne père elle va perdre
il a mangé sur un petit cigare fou elle
perd tout simplement est ce que le plus
beau et pas très avancé donc le roi sera
devant l'opinion en finale en fait de
roanne champion c'est assez facile de
savoir si vous êtes gagner on a trois
petits avantages potentiels si vous avez
deux sur trois quelle que soit la
position vous êtes toujours gagnant
c'est petit avantage en finale de roi
c'est lé soin à voir l'opposition
c'est-à-dire de repasser à la deûle à
l'assomption
derrière son roi ils vont terminer pas
là nul j'essaie de vous expliquer c'est
un bien
du coup dans ses célèbres tels qu'il a
paris il a refusé la victoire matériel
saisi dans le final de roi les gagnants
si votre pion si votre roi et devant
votre pion c'est un des trois davantage
si potentiellement 22 pions comme vous
allez les blancs et sur la 6ème
embaucher et le troisième petit avantage
potentiel c'est croire l'opposition m
voir en face du roi adverse si vous avez
deux sur trois vous êtes
systématiquement gago
si vous avez donc sur trois cellules 0
sur 3 7l 3 sur 3 à gagner ça normal ça
vous fassiez de la ville pour au
contraire ici la grosse erreur de ma
terreur c'est d'avoir avancé ses pions
en fait notre pions dans les finales
droit il nous sert à perdre un temps
abandonnée est ce que le but avec notre
force et d'escorter notre pions sur la
case d'arrivée bien sûr donc on devra
chasser le roi adverse
par exemple cette position là comme
l'anglais c'est un peu n'importe quoi
juste le but c'est d'arriver comme ça de
chasser le roi adverse et donc ensuite
de libérer le couloir pour donne qui ont
passé et de le transformer en dame
du coup d'éclat il nous sert à perdre un
tel point et si l'autre pour
l'opposition on pourra toujours jouer un
coup de coeur pour pouvoir reprendre
ensuite comment c'est pas si difficile
il suffit de l'apprendre
donc voilà effectivement la place ils
pouvaient gagner atabi script
ok c'est dur ma terreur mais a quand
même noter le beau jeu de ton adversaire
tu a sacrifié le cac valeo a je crois
juste pour le spectacle pour relancer le
suspense
donc c'est une nulle quand même pas
immérité pour lui et salue le futur il
ya une bulle du coup cette finale mais
le gaffeur fois sacrifié une pièce pour
le fair play on nous offrir du suspense
ensuite c'est beaucoup plus compliqué et
matin a super bien joué avec 7,2
secondes là rien ne s'est passé jusqu'à
la toute fin
et pendant ce temps on a un choc au
sommet entre eux où ils crachent ue et
barbarian de vainqueur de koh varela
avec ckoi l'utile matériel a eu d'accord
il ya une tour pour pour trois pions
c'est particulier de revenir vite fait
voir ce qui s'est passé dans cette
partie sur une espèce de système de
londres aller assez vite pour voit
l'action total c'est de voir comment les
noirs ont sacrifié pièces en tête qu'ils
ont sacrifié par des fonds ils se sont
fait attaquer on passe par mater auquel
il a pris 11,5 ont cassé axe entre hees
a activé sa série que ça avait l'air
tentons nomura les lignes ont souscrit à
des cases et on mange trois pions c'est
assez intéressant
la changer des dames est d'eyl ah oui
allez il a bien dû il a perdu une
qualité associée la tour est bloqué à
défense du cavalier on se retrouve dans
cette position avec 4 pions
contre une tour c'est particulier à
jouer c'est pas toujours facile pour la
tour pour le camp qui à la tour de plus
que les deux villes
en fait souvent l'idée à être de rendre
une pièce dans des conditions pour deux
ou trois pions et comme ça ça nous
permet de gagner assez assez facilement
vous mais vous trouvez vraiment le bon
timing pour rendre cette pièce ils
n'arrivent pas toujours et surtout mbits
à plus de 30 secondes pour pour
barbarian on va voir si c'est le petit
russe arriva à trouver le moment idéal
pour prendre du matériel
est-ce que c'est maintenant avec tout
reprendre des 3 pourquoi pas ça
casserait ses pions liées derrières vous
pourrez récupérer c'est ce qu'ils jouent
mes cavaliers on décale je pensais qu'il
voulait venir au b 4 on mange dehors des
deux pions l'idée c'est vraiment de
casser cette chaîne
[Musique]
je pense que pratiquement c'est un bon
choix
la barre des blancs même si la balance
matériel et un peu moins avantageuses
maintenant alors ça c'est un peu j'adore
la tour qui mangent en c3 quand même
plus le nombre de pions serait induit
aussi voulu potentiellement sur le long
terme ça peut être dangereux pour les
blancs se retrouver avec un tour
cavaliers contre tours un truc comme ça
avec insuffisance matériel on en est
encore loin il reste trois poumons
le retour el farissi mettre la pression
sur le club
4 objectivement ça va être gagnant pour
les blancs mais en pratique il ya trois
points pour la pièce c'est pas si facile
notre cavalier kahn très bien installés
en d4
il peut à loisir reculé pour essayer de
créer des menaces et faire tomber le
purgatoire il assure avoir essayé de
défendre coûte que coûte
non il ne s'en prendront curage 4
pourquoi pas des gens qui sont dans
leurs trente dernières secondes foulée 2
c'est joli c'était un esthète ses
mobiles très chaud on reconnaît bien là
préfèrent la joliette à l'efficacité
parfois peut lui jouer des tours dans
cette position c'était précis alors on
est 3 qui défend tous je souhaite
rentrer que ses atours d'encaisser des
pions l échange un convaincu peut-être
qu'il n'a pas trouvé de meilleure
solution barbarians à lui permet de
gagner un pion ok pourquoi pas mais
c'est d'envoyer pas dans ces deux
pionniers mais quand même c'est que la
tour blanche pas assez facilement s'en
prendre à b6 et danse assez bien joué
j'avais pas vu lors du tour des deux
tours 3-2 et elle sera plus qu'un pion
aux blancs commencent à faire juste pour
débutants intermédiaires c'est peut-être
encore très bien joué pour éviter de
perdre achète par brahim qui sont hyper
mal an dont 7 dans cette finale a trouvé
beaucoup de ressources à jouer des
pleins de très beaux coups pratiques et
maintenant voilà il veut changer le
dernier pion blanc alors bien sûr bien
sûr s'y était refusé par will cruciaux
seule option c'est son ticket pour la
victoire il a besoin de le conserver
et là j'ai trouvé qu'il avait très bien
joué jusqu'ici d'art variable mais
malheureusement il a laissé quand même
le grand blond s'activer au rayon des
tempos catégorique juste envoyer ses
pions
c'est très difficile ma jambe quelques
secondes la position et huard a joué
maintenant ça devrait gagner pour les
blancs
wilcke rechute devrait perdre armes sans
trop de soucis ban qui va certainement
abandonner c'était vraiment très bien
battu avec sa tour de moi continue mais
messi pour will rock you c'est la sienne
dans le temps voilà je pense que le
dernier coup de la partie si elles ont
été instructifs malgré tout avec ses
gros déséquilibre matérielles difficiles
à jouer
j'arrive encore sur une partie qui se
termine pile-poil n'a pas d'humour est
folle elle est encore aujourd'hui même
si la partie touché à sa fin peut-être
entre john travolta de john travolta
polonais qui se prend deux tours sur la
seconde qu'il n'est jamais une bonne
nouvelle donc si maugrée voilà il ya de
vrais pouvoirs à gagner ça assez
facilement
ils parlent mal quand même à bord il
comprend la 4g 2 mais il ya le fou qui
va arriver dans la compta caudal pour
proche d'eux doit être une affaire de
quelques coups salut des galax us c'est
une barque de portable ds galactus ou un
joli petit panel faut laver qui termine
en beauté
il a mis son fou comme prédit dans la
grande diagonale et derrière le bâton un
show était imparable
parce que si vous voulez fermer cet ego
dame ou libérer le contrôle la cage et 2
et c'était le matin dacic avec les deux
tours qu'il faut un bisou au roi dans le
petit coin ou que très belle victoire de
démographes alive on va relancer une
partie entre tana et manu guignard nous
on est encore à la sortie une ouverture
ici on a une pile pour un enfermement de
faux c'est le confinement ici pour vous
3 manu guignât qui habitent les
consignes à la lettre
c'est bien joué de sa part même si la
ramq a fait des dégâts second jour là
c'est pas grave on n'est pas pressé pour
moi je ne fous il va nulle part ce faut
donc on défend d'abord le contre jeu
adverse et maintenant d'en casser le
matériel donc dû guignard qui pourrait
vous rapporter une partie sous nos yeux
et baye et par le monde contre jeu pour
les blancs il ya un seul petit plus haut
à fougères cas c'est bien jouer encore
une fois d'intérieur et la structure du
roi albert
on a beaucoup de choses sur la colonne
est potentiellement dont qui cite un
mail qui est roux qui est donc dur et
glisse à tour c'est un peu vite de se
précipiter sur les changes à la manu qui
aurait même pu se montrait bien plus
gourmand donc et sans la tour d2 la
victoire devrait pas lui échapper pour
autant il a une place de plus en finale
il à gaz magnifique pour son cavalier au
f4 les fous de couleur opposait sait
favorise la bulle en national en
matériel a réduit quand il reste plein
de pièces sur l'échiquier vous de cauet
reposer il favorise au contraire en
attaque et c'en était trop pour talent
elle qui a rendu son dernier souffle et
qui à l'insu ou abandonnés a raison avec
avec 4 qui arrive et on pourra
s'intéresser à une nouvelle partie est
ce qu'on sera fait un petit coup de seb
le canot mettre à table dans le tournoi
c'est intéressant de voir c'est parti il
affronte un joueur - foire et manuel
marquez a classé r 1700 ou avant
justement comment comment il se défend
ici là il va poser des problèmes un
petit peu à ces aides avec les blogs
qu'est ce qui s'est passé tel est le
simple d'être très théorique car lé g4
je connais mieux
cavalier 1,4 avec dd 5 kg 4 je ne sais
pas trop comment ça marche en tweed mais
je fais confiance à seb là-dessus il n'y
a pas de problème sur la théorie
alors cette variante les bleus ont
sacrifié un pion en dix ans on a des
activités on est mieux développés est
alors un peu au centre même si les noirs
ou la possibilité de faire convaincre
les blancs est aussi toujours récupérer
l'une des quatre à tout moment gros rock
a été julien c'était important de
s'enlever de cette vis-à-vis roa tour de
voir une partie assez spectaculaire ici
avec des recomposée c'est assez chaud g3
j'aime pas trop j'ai trois n'était pas
nécessaire d'être canalisé bien le
travail de défenseur de la h 2a limite
je préfère h3 pour chasser l'intrus
plutôt que j'ai trois je trouve que des
trous sur quatre broches
j'ai pas fait du coup wildcat ici voit
sa part ben c'est plutôt bien joué ou a
forcé f 6 1 par le choix du cavalier qu
il faut le défendre
salut piotr et salut pour le vide à tort
j'allais te voir après du coup capote
masqué fire 2004 une danse 2004 des
caillons compterait saviem dommage
jacques doillon une set c'est une belle
perf
c'est toujours le plusieurs de conclure
surtout contre un joueur supposé vont
plus fort que soi d'obtenir des bonnes
positions après faut l'achever
et ça c'est très difficile parce qu'il
va seulement trouvé beaucoup de
ressources plus que nos adversaires
habituels dans cette pause
sion s'est compliquée et du g5 qui va
aimer pour les pour les noirs mais aussi
des cavaliers prend la tête pour les
blancs c'est pas forcément cigares de ce
qu'il n'y a pas d'âme qui peut revenir
au raca soutenir le cavalier donc
finalement pour manger ce pour un set on
a perdu beaucoup de temps avec les plans
et espions 27 c'est pas grave par
rapport à l'abri du roi noir il n'est
pas en danger pour autant la colonne à
n'est pas ouverte
si elle noire qui devrait avoir
l'avantagé grâce à leur force entre
leurs dames centralisée qui est très
puissante ici ont des 5
c'est bien joué bien joué de la part des
manuels qui fait une bonne partie quand
même avec les blue ici contre celles
crées des menaces alors que 4 avec
l'idée ne peut pas manger en rocade
parce que la dame défaut bessac main
autour d un cacou très naturel il faut
c'est simple je pense que c'est une gare
de saly si tu peux a priori adam prend
1,4 il a coupé la liaison ici la coupe
est l'idée dame prend place à bord d'un
premier cas donc je pense qu'il perdait
juste son pion central
il s'en sort j'ai dit elle s'en sort
bien mais pas forcément parce que kessel
fera finalement c'est peut-être encore
plus fort que dame prend 1,4 bonjour sur
le clouage voyez ces deux compliqué ici
s'habiller je la joue et détroit la
raison c'est compliqué mais kelly prend
destin que c'est bien joué
grosse partir de là la mare qui a priori
un plomb plus il devrait pouvoir
stabiliser un celle ci si on arrive à
s'en sortir avec les droits aux gens qui
essaient 3ème sur quatre est faible donc
celle qui est un peu dans le dur ici
quand on le regarde je passe une poisse
et pourquoi s'en sortir
plutôt café mais il ya un temps pour
tout un piètre j'ai envie de te dire en
ce moment plutôt thé
après le repas plutôt café salue ses
fûts à l'embarras si il trouve des
ressources et de joueurs parce que s'il
a un fou déjà contre le cavalier créer
de tactique des petits pièges c'est un
peu plus difficile
option 1 4 pas une très faible qui peut
pas faire grand chose pour lui parce que
attaqué trois fois à des cultures case
blanche pourra pas se faire d'effort
dans une troisième fois sur ces quatre
attaquants aux cavaliers bons objets qui
vont les noirs se battre pour la bulle
des mais voilà il suffit que je dise ça
pour ça tourne tout avec 4,6 de
clairvaux pour 2 s'est imposée à
défendre sa seconde arranger c'était
primordial pour les blancs
et maintenant non je vois bien celle
l'emporter ici et le petit coup de pouce
qu'il avait besoin de gestion b2 le pion
sait car c'est une fusée et le couple
tofu supérieur beaucoup plus pour
cavaliers les deux pièces et 50 très
bien ensemble surtout quand dans la tour
sur la seconde rangée une cavale il
avoir du mal à défendre contre un pion
passé il a même parfois avoir du mal à
se sacrifier tout court contre le clou
et du coup le plan des manuels
je le comprends mais il est beaucoup
trop long il appartient pas trop à la
position alors ici des 100 qu'ils soient
payés 30 et 3 va jusque tour à 3 pour
gagner la pièce grâce au cloud âge il
n'y a pas d'échec pas d'échec et surtout
pour apprendre du fou est comme ça vous
serez en sécurité les autres nouveaux
pions s'est passé pour l'emporter
et du coup c'est blanc remporté comme ça
donc ça pardonne pas quand vous jouez
contre 1,1 fort joueur le moindre petit
oubli retourne la position de ces
dommages un pourvoi ils en ont fait une
très très bonne partie avec les blancs
et avoir laissé ses retours sur la
seconde rangée ça a suffi à lancer une
partie de barbarians ici qu'à les blancs
contre gorale celle qui est quand même
très chaud il a fait un petit peu peur
quand un gros écart des lots on va voir
si ils arrivent à poser autant de
problèmes que dans la partie précédente
morales qui rejoint abertis voit souvent
aussi dans ses arénas
pour l'instant il est plutôt très bien
sortie de l'ouverture il a une position
très solide son objectif va être de
jouer des cinq se débarrasser de son
mariage et en d6 est un petit peu faible
et toutes ces pièces sont en position
pour jouer des saints s'est dit pourquoi
pas j'y vais le seul petit problème
c'est que des fois dans lequel on
baissait un peu faible et on n'a pas
forcément envie de perdre notre fougue
cases blanches mais ok dessin de sa fait
complètement sens dans cette position va
voir comment barbarian réagi est ce
qu'il est en vie par exemple de tolérer
un des quatre ou pas pourrait créer un
trou passées au noir est fermée de fou
oui ce qui va manger en d5
il ya deux tours des cahiers c'est ça
qui a plein de coups possibles c'est
pour les blancs beaucoup de candidats
salut mystère
darcos a bien prononcé une orange ont
des styles et à sang
glee 6 mon cher ami les dunes fait
souvent la faute également perçu un
poulpe est d'accord je relirai plus des
articles parce que c'est ça faire sens a
dit pas ça fait sens ouais ça se disant
langage courant make sense l'art sens
c'est que les gens le disent tellement
aller crise d'abbas et met à l'oral
ce sera tous les règles cela a du sens
tout bêtement
oui mais ça sort de manière moins fluide
plus trop cela a du sens
un petit peu pédant cela a du sens très
cher ça fait sens face à bath plus que
des autoroutes ça fait sans doute mais
mais je te la corde pour les québécois
sais pas comment dire on dit ça au
québec certainement une manière très
bizarre il a tort mais énorme c'est pas
du pédantisme
mon instinct par marianne qui se
penchera plutôt bien mais mes chorale
qui fait toujours une bonne partie est
toujours seul à s'être inscrits en
avant-poste ans et 500 km du contre j'ai
4 5 c'est une partie intéressante on
ferait pas ça faisait moins quatre
écoutes ça remonte à plus de dix ans la
prépa pour moi et puis de toute façon
plus j'ai mieux j'écrivais on va dire
moi j'avais des pannes note quand je
faisais des phrases de trois mois au
sujet verbe complément le prouver très
heureux quand je mettais 18 adjectifs
qui était peut-être excessif
j'avais moins quatre par adjectif jobs
des pubs d'inata ça fait sens que tu te
fais ce qu ils font c
se battre alors sa principale difficulté
sera peut-être gérer la pendule avec ses
18 secondes à ban ki de donner le fou là
c'est un choix vraiment intéressant d'un
point de vue stratégique avec la reprise
du pion ma tante un cavalier qui est
ancré sur la casse et sincère
d'avant-postes stabilisé il sera jamais
déloger le pion à six est voué à tomber
derrière nadal 3 4 qui va aller très
très vite en les noix peuvent espérer un
peu de contrôle sur carte blanche autour
du roi mais ça va être difficile à
organiser on va voir c'est jamais la
dame est un parti un petit peu aux
fraises est tournée il faut garder les
pieds six siècles - c'est sous il se
retrouve maintenant à plus on fait des
changes
moins de chance pratique persiste ici
avant c'est très facile pour bavaria va
juste mettre son pion à 5 à 6 y a plus
assez de matériel pour inquiéter ce
croit et c'est l'abandon mais c'était
connu tout une bonne partie chorale avec
les drailles c'est un battus alors
qu'ils qui n'avoue pas vu alors nazis
zougrana qui commence une partie avec
les douars contre capannelle zoug end
dans l'envié d'aller voir kms vous
guidons s'allume au greffe aulaye numéro
2 j'ai oublié d'aller voir cas pas de
masque encore je t'ai pas vu pour
l'instant pas vu ton pseudo
j'en doute papoul pda tard
c'est improvisa bah tu ne sais pas ce
qu'on peut dire du slam c'est la peintre
officiel de la cité ici je n'ai pas la
réf mais c'est trop et pour monstres
aziz google éditions face à la paire de
très bien se passer
faire très attention et que noir sous ce
genre d'ouverture en te sens d'autres
fous très vite scalaires logique on a un
peu actif on abandonne protection du
pion p7 on est très jeune sur quatre
blanche et clément il a exploité tout de
suite en jugement dan b3 b6 a fait des
gros trop directement le cadre très bien
jouer et gagner en tempo pour lui
libérer le fou ou gamma est ici quand on
va de tueurs et là il ya le cahier c6
cia cook avons prise est une pièce de
plus pour les blancs un centre monstres
des cinq pompes qui tombe cette triple
carton rouge pour 10 go galicien s'est
très mal passée cette partie c'est la
miniature
[Musique]
c'est pas où il crée chou qui contredira
guy à la lettre affûté attention peut
terminer par un petit mâle d'abc ca le
son la monnaie qui a sorti 10 ou du
terrain c'était violence qui seul est
basée la violence est repartie
démonstration de gabonais impressionnant
[Musique]
thiam nous voir là une 4 en plus qu'ils
allaient devoir être ibrahim
il est l ouverture ici souvent avec les
blancs on va quant au maintien attention
que de fermer immédiatement par ces cinq
vraiment pas pressé de prendre ce genre
de décisions radicales fans c'est que
dentaire un petit peu notre fou est bon
je suis un peu circonspecte cette
décision at-il mais ok rien de rien de
grave au corps a été un petit peu du
temps avec les lourdes avec les noirs
s'ils voulaient mettre mon four m soit
pas autant et en faisant indirectement
et à cluj et kalil permet aux blancs de
sortir leur fougue gratuitement
convaincu les cette perte de temps vous
échec les temps ou souvent décisif
on avance on va revenir au direct nous
sommes un petit peu fermé la colonie a
fait c'est finalement ouverte crois que
c'est ça le futur
c'était le coup de boule au site google
le retour du bâton de l'islam
intel table ça tout ça peut marcher à
l'islam peut-être prochaine
soit la mode un petit concours d'islam
exactement vikings
c'est un peu différent à lorient et
cavaliers qui s'est introduit en u6 il
aurait bien besoin d'une case en plus
pour ses atouts on a travaillé ça va il
va quand même prouvé une c'était juste
c'est la fourchette
le cavalier on voit que ibrahim rajoute
pas avec une seule pièce je n'ai besoin
que de bons cavaliers pour te domine l
on va voir s'ils continuent avec cette
technique jusqu'au bout peut-être qu'un
jour il aura quand même besoin d'activer
son dada mais pour l'instant là c'est le
super kangourou qui fait le travail qui
va manger la torah habite et qu'il
arrive à ressortir c'est beaucoup moins
sûr
simplement un cavalier à six semble
stopper les ardeurs mais mais il aura
quand même fait un bon bout de chemin et
récolter du matériel au passage qu'il
assure ibrahim ici c'est un peu
l'impression qu'on a avalé trop bref une
partie cas pour vous pouvez d'abord à
jouer d'avoir le droit de jouer que sur
une moitié de l'échiquier pourquoi pas
c'est un concept à creuser des
nombreuses variantes qui n'ont pas
encore été exploré malgré toutes les
propositions
il ya du jeu pour les droits acquis et
b4 qu'ils étaient trois à kaïs et de du
fait de cette même activité blanche
faire attention dans la boue même si
dumas des avants plus pas certain mais
les blancs ici il faut situer ibrahim en
mode
moi je m'en fous de de méprise toujours
5 voilà qui va faire pareil là pas le
droit de jouer avec ses pièces de
l'album vous est quand même très dur de
gagner ici dame ne donne toujours pas au
moins ils parlaient menaces mais l'homme
a pris la toux qui va rentrer yano fou
et une case en plus lui jouait qu'avec
trois pièces en plus donc il ya des
chances que ça paye j allais je me sens
bien je sens bien au 26e coup n'ont
toujours pas toi réf
ibrahim qui est dans le running gag ici
les échanges et les dames et du coup il
reste que ça il reste plus que sar est
obligé de les jouer des sons oui le 29e
coup fut le bon le cavalier sortie de
maliens en plus sûrement triomphale
parce qu'avec les blancs avec les noirs
en ce temps là une case en plus il a
échangé toutes les pièces alors qu'il
aurait certes bien vite fait en arrière
si ouais c'est un peu dommage qu'il ait
changé des pièces en fait il a forcé son
adversaire presque à jouer avec les
autres ils auraient dû rentrer dans son
jus pouvez manger à chaque certainement
des réseaux douzaine de matchs donc
échanger des dap à la meilleure des
idées on va quand même revenir pour voir
et ça y est on a raté le moment où la
tour est sorti de son père kyle là comme
toujours le phocéen qui avons pris
d'ailleurs au passage toujours en prise
je me fais de miss clic c'est le foot à
bout ça y'est gaz en plus ce qu'il a vu
ça n'aurait pas le sourire parce que le
pratiquent le pur moi ici pour très vite
même s'il a deux pièces mineurs pour la
tour maintenant qu'ils ont à sa nouvelle
fusée
les cavaliers sont très très lent pour
attraper un et à la course
la conseillère gay para para ibrahim qui
du coup au rail et son pari utilisons
que la moitié de ses pièces ont être le
premier coup
pas facile kazan plus
quillan sa dernière fois dans la
bataille mais je crains que ce point
suffisant j'ai presque cru au bâton pour
cette position si la tour était ensuite
j'avais pattes ça aurait été vraiment
une très belle fin à cette partie avec
une tour à une dame de plus est on
arrivé à cette position et la pâte et
ibrahim sylla bulls vraiment un sens de
l'humour très développé il aurait pu
jouer cavalier b1 ici il serait fait
match nul
gotaas esthétique quand même moi je leur
ai fait je pense juste pour la beauté du
geste
un ban de qualité moi je pense que
partir très instructive vallée seront
alors drague ono qui commence une partie
avec les plots ici contre ntp
lalalalalalalalala deux joueurs bien
classés à voir ce que ça donne ceci yann
clairay que ces trois ici ok mais comme
ça j'imagine que les deux joueurs
doivent être assez habituel aux gens de
position jeu
nous sommes cette fois ci n est pas très
familiers de genre de schéma en moi qui
ai une idée ici pour les noix ou si
c'est un peu trop ambitieux sa valeur
comme envisageable
c'est ça certainement
ils échangent pourquoi pas puisque pas
là pour le beau jeu comme dans la partie
d'avant
j'utilise toutes leurs pièces des
changes moins spectaculaire avec plaisir
bewise c'est dommage parce que tu étais
super perd au final après après qu'ils
aient à manger ta qualité tu avais
normalement 2 contre je voudrais juste
te du essayer de garder les pièces sur
l'échiquier pour l'attaqué quant à du
matériel en moi t'as pas intérêt à
favoriser les échanges de toute façon
ces dragages général mais qui s'applique
quand même très souvent surtout ici sont
rois étaient faibles donc échanger des
pièces lourdes ça ne pouvait lui être
que favorable à l'or dans cette partie
les échanges qui s'enchaînent en chêne
de hêtre ou à part voilà c'est accepter
que la différence principale c'est comme
un trois contre deux pour les blancs
allèles d'armes et à 3 contre 4 allée
droit à ces mineurs ou une attaque de
majorité et les noirs qui essaie de
prendre un petit peu de l'espace a
raison je dirais la dame peut-être du f4
qui va venir mais ça paraît comme
difficile de mettre en par des attaques
là bien sûr pour faire très attention à
toi 17 doubles et trois échecs
elle s'est doublée sur l'accolade dé
drame au no 5 rues et à filtrer que
notamment réussi ce pourquoi pas les a
menacés peut-être pas grand-chose et le
stress
4 f3 voulait avoir une case de replier
clément pour son fou sur f4 mais des
fois c'était intéressant ici à du f4
existent avec des idées f3 j'aime bien
ce genre d'idée systématique points pour
les noirs ou vraiment passé le rock
adverse sur la prise catastrophique
parce que le roi ce serait vraiment dans
les courants d'air ici et si on n'avance
pas il ya quand même un point crois
qu'ils y perdent puissant hilbert
dangereux donc c'est très dur à traiter
pour les blondes genre de position il a
choisi de le reprendre le pion ne pas
dire plus servat triste et on en est là
maintenant les fous sont échangées ne
reste plus que les pièces lourdes sur
l'échiquier le point 4 qui peut être
sauvé par tour et vite
et du coup est clairement une arme puis
si c'est plutôt les doigts elle est là
la nana qui joue pour les deux résultats
je dirais un peu mieux le roi blu ray
est un peu plus faible qui génère google
norbert dragon beaucoup référence harry
potter est là je lai
ce avance dangereusement voire même voir
le stoppeur mais m j'ai pris cette
machine arrière ici tour odéon
j'ai peur qu'elle compte ou passif ça se
passe pas très bien
[Musique]
et merci dsk là dessus ce qui est abonné
pour la 4e quatrième mois d'affilée
dames et deux échecs simplifiée et
surtout surtout rentrer sur la seconde
rangée
c'est bien sûr le thème récurrent défi
là quand on a les blancs l'aiment
après deux tours au 7e avec les avec les
noirs into en seconde pour éviter d'y
récolter tous les petites choses loris
il malgré tout même des choses qui sont
sorties avec les bleus puisque le
matériel et réduit donc drague au dos il
peut toujours espérer sauver la nul
surtout si ces deux-là parviennent à
s'échanger d'une façon ou d'une autre
ensuite ce sera très dur pour les
revêtements de progresser il pourra
faire blocus objections ça devrait être
lu ici mais elle a quand même falloir
aller les 17 nul lui suffit d'attendre
touche à rien je pense être très dur de
progresser pour le noir ou avoir voir ce
qui se passe intéressant cette finale
mais la pression voilà ils sont 100 web
les droits ont pas le temps de jouer ses
cartes on pourra jouer g4 nous mêmes
avec les blancs ici c'est important
voilà j'ai quatre l'hémato va récupérer
le tour ou trois ou quatre ans qui
aimons faire nul donc c'est bien défendu
dans l'accord dans cette finale c'est
quand même difficile pour lui de base et
ld la la la il veut pas lâcher la lune
comme ça ils gardent les tours mais
alors ici il a proposé nul finalement il
n'y a pas de cas où il arrive à griller
sa pensée explique une dizaine de
minutes et c'est très serré où il crèche
ou et euros mais c'est le petit russe
kaka points d'avance julian est pas loin
derrière des plumes au greffe aulaye
en embuscade haussier alors voir bon
live c'est la fin de la partie ou
essaient de trouver deux parties
commencera peut-être sur un petit peu la
course aux nano-objets de regarder on a
les deux leaders qui s'affrontent donc
seb outre et oui le crush ou celle qui
veut à tout prix gagner avec les plans
d'une situation demeure ce twin pour le
dépasser certainement la partie qui va
décider la victoire dans cette arène a
joué son approche classique avec le
double turquetto qui maîtrise à la
perfection jamais agréable de jouer
contre ça avec les noirs pour notre
adversaire de 13,1 et souvent d'obtenir
des concessions
et là c'est ce qui s'est passé faiblesse
santé ciss vous plus active envers c'est
donc maintenant normalement il va juste
torture et torturés ou i cry ou la
séance au du lun au goulag aux
courbatures aux russes ici pas défendre
toutes ses faiblesses est très difficile
et très passif le mieux à faire dans ces
cas là si on y arrive bien sûr ces deux
souvent rendre un pion un peu moins
sacrifier un pion pour s être activée
plutôt que de juste le suggère on voit
aussi énorme pression autant mise par
seb qui a trois minutes entre moins
d'une minute pour will rock you tu
attends rose qui en difficulté et là je
vois que ce qu'il se passe un petit
poème de connexion peut être est ce que
ça donne moi j'ai vu son son ton son
temps qui clignote du c'est pas moi je
dis pas
direct s'est passé plein de trucs on
était comme ça il faut prouver cette
pour belleville et il s'est fait encore
un peu peur dans la toute première
partie une petite pointe tactique obligé
de sacrifier la qualité du pro et mange
points de lyon ok on a une finale ici
avec deux pions que le fou contre la
tour voilà les deux pions ne sont pas
passés liés auquel cas les blancs
pourraient vraiment je veux pour la
victoire ce qui est je vois pas trop
d'autre résultat que la nu la priory mon
roi blanc peut vraiment aller soutenir
le plan parce qu'il abandonnerait sonder
le roi avec noah on peut rien faire
normalement non plus passé paraît très
compliqué du coup cette finale qui
devrait se solder par là nul qui fait la
sphère de will crouch ou qu'ils
maintiendraient à distance c'est
peut-être qu'un autre dépend souvent
pourrait venir pour les dix dernières
minutes
juste à temps d'ici je pense pas trop
car aucun plan de garantie matin pour
les deux camps si vraiment l'un d'eux et
c'est trop forcer 7/4 ip non c'est pas
ça qui arrive bel élan wilks rescue qui
a et b c'est le drame diact elle sut
cloud et celles qui gagnent la partie et
certainement la reine de la sorte
ouais là c'est là c'est l'âge tant que
la cedh jura pour une crèche ue a souri
certainement un peu un peu trop grosse
pour lui a manipulé et du coup la glisse
et de ses 2 1
l'accident bête et du coup classement il
se fait de 10 fait il se fait rattraper
par parcelle mais celle qui maintenant
est dans une stricte de victoire qu'il a
marqué le plus de points
je crains pour être un sympathisant
russe que je sois décisif alors après
mon assiette qui affronte mondial paul
eid donc je vais rester là dessus quand
même parce que la haine ce jour victoire
finale je suis vraiment sur ces les
confrontations cyber seraient pour une
fois
la gamine partir intéressant entre un
maître et un maître ville encore aux
poses de regarder ça va quand même eu le
temps de bien explorer un peu tout le
monde
depuis le début cette arène celle qu'il
veut impérativement du coup gagné avec
les doigts pour profiter du ripage sur
l'adversaire puis la partie d'avant
avoir commencé ensemble regrette voilà
il ce petit peu le rôle d'arbitré genre
de but souffre d'être assez typique pour
les deux joueurs qui ont l'habitude de
jouer c'est varié donc là un peu forcé
de reprendre de bay sirpe rende des
tarifs de très mal se passer
l'actuel 5 des quatre qui va arriver
toutes les ligues vont s'ouvrir ce sera
clairement en faveur des noirs du coup
ils le jouent morello line ou contredit
va avoir 6 10 m est d'accord avec moi et
s'il arrive à exploiter ça que cinq ici
malheur comme très prometteur alors
certains bien sûr il ya des idées aussi
pour les plans email je pose que le jeu
au centre est prépondérant surtout avec
les deux fois les deux grandes
diagonales
alors comment on joue et c'est ce qu'on
recule au bout des quatre ils jouent des
quatre hockey qui doit quand même être
bourges pense là on n'a pas le choix on
doit manger le fou avec blanc maintenant
on va certainement je me 3ds qui va
reprendre le 3 faisait que maintenant
c'était purement ils sont très faibles
qu'eux
du coup au cep devrait pouvoir les
cueillir assez facilement ils se
retrouvent avec son fou le cadre noir je
vais avoir un rôle très important à
jouer et pas mal de faiblesse chez les
blondes qui s'y rend vraiment priori
contre x tu reprendras 2b la prochaine
fois moins que fallout c'est pas grave
ça se passera mieux
je comprend un tube et jouer avec tes
deux pour passer lui aussi mais c'est un
petit peu dangereux quand même on va se
tourner ça en plus pas de l'enlever ce
sera certainement moins vrai dans once a
beaucoup d'eux d'un processeur c'est un
flottement ici et les blancs crise ou
tombés les uns après les autres
éducatrices et gecas sable under la
partir d'un coup ça reste une idée quand
même si la dame joue sur jouer à chicago
le 4 7 qui voudraient intégrale de son
fou quoi pas ça libère comme un peu des
cases aussi pour les pièces blanches
puis le bouquet qui parviennent à jouer
avec aussi un moment donné a
certainement avec le nord et y tour on
s'est vite un jour au l'autre au pour
lutter contre ce fléau reste à voir
comment on arrive à organiser ces deux
cavaliers a certainement un ou deux
tours c'est un amour données toi je sais
pas faut s'enlever marijuana 3a je crois
il fait des trois fait des trous sur
cases noires c'est la très très beau
voyage 3 il a eu peur de kelly g4
certainement que vous comprendrez ou
alors ya peut-être des dames prend 1,4
et si vous
on sent que les noirs sont bien beau
fouiller un peu plus
je pense que cavalia achetant local vous
ou michele avec des idées de jeu mais f5
aller chez trois fous et cinq ans bien
sûr à l'eiblen trouveront des ressources
pour essayer de contrarier tout ça mais
celle qui a réfléchi à un membre
important de la partie il est fini par
dégoûter jean cavalier à chocques
alors il n'y avait pas de 1.4 qui a
toujours des problèmes et c'est tout à
la fin 5 au début j'avais envie de la
jouer en c1 et vous prend ses trois
carrières de gagner des matelles
sur-le-champ ici à une fourchette à la
fin de la guerre donc c'est ce carré du
calcul el-assad est ce qu'il y avait une
bonne réponse ici quand les blancs du
cépage donc c'est difficile était à mon
avis obligé de sacrifier du matériel
peut-être que si c'était lé moins
catastrophistes la jemaye priori ça doit
perdre assez confortablement
donc il ya eu la pièce qu'ils étaient
perdus au c3 et en plus en plus on est
noir qui attaquent le seul qui contre
jeu des blancs 7 pions c'est vous qui
sera très basse île maurice donc mais
barrios est vite fait qu'ici la victoire
vraiment on les bras au noir
celle qui rend
paul pour remporter sa première le croit
comme à rennes a fait respecter son
classement elo son titre de maître
international sa souris de qualité par
rapport à certains de ses adversaires
aussi
bref voilà il ya hélas 2 minutes 20 au
tournoi de la meilleure chose de me
référer serait presque d'arriver au bout
la partie ne puisse pas se terminer
sauf que malgré un créneau je ne pense
pas qu'il ait parmi aliciens la 40
secondes qui doit transformer en deux
minutes prolongée vu qu'il vient de
d'oublier sa tour cette fois ci est il
arrivé lui aussi je ne sais pas je pense
pas cette fois ci c'est l'abandon
c'est l'abandon et donc au classement
voilà celle qui passe à 49 alors que
will creux fiona que 45
mais s'ils voient une dernière partie
dont les deux dernières minutes
quelqu'un qu'on n'a pas trop vu c'est
possible si tu trouves qui trouve des
formules comme ça pour faire plaisir à
patator à les kalachs merci de le voir
plusieurs fois à chaque fois c'était la
fin finalement les thèmes parti qui
affronte ina aide pour encore pas suivi
il manque une dame
il manque une dame à l'amicale h qu'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est la fourchette à
là il était plutôt très bien que s'il
avère d'avoir beaucoup de plomb de plus
avec les noirs visuellement c'est très
agressive je ne sais pas il a plutôt plu
tenait à 3 points au plus pour les
droits et une attaque prometteuse sur la
colonne jane est certainement
complètement gagnant et il a mis sa dame
là où il fallait pas alors ici elle un
petit à petit fait nouveau la main au
bout dans le diable pour gagner que les
noirs très facilement
madame procès qui est terminé la partie
avec la fourchette gagner une qualité on
se retrouvait avec l'euro sécurité sur
les dames avec une vérité trois ponts
plus pour les noirs qui l'a raté il a
raté à la base c'est lui qui s'est pris
la prochaine fois yann est donc
maintenant il a une dame de moi mais il
avait rejoint la bande hull ne perdra
pas la partie de ce type on va
certainement donc en rester là
monga folle et a fait n'importe quoi il
s'excuse auprès de mauvais faux la
numéro deux et voilà donc victoire de
seb
et oui les crèches ou qui s'est pas
remis de son mystique la même brevet
radieux tête derrière dont il a eu la
belle pour ne finir que sa partie
suivante c'est du coup fait chiper la
médaille d'argent par julien julien
capitaine de lionax mois sur le top-12
of mind games un joli podium ici avec
trois ans très beau joueur et belle
victoire de cette excitation
je propose une cagnotte pour une souris
pour huiler crochet ou peut être pour la
prochaine fois si vous voulez la merci à
tous d'avoir participé vous êtes presque
80 si ça fait beaucoup et ça fait plus
d'un mois et demi qu'on fait c'est à
rennes du coup lundi demain on essaiera
de faire un jazz 966 vous voulez pour
changer un petit peu
j'essaierai de jouer ici et de montrer
généreux et d'ici là vous allez rendez
vous dans une grosse heure à partir de
16h je crois avec avec qu'elle est femme
pour poursuivre le jeune espoir français
avec notamment marc andré amaury dit et
puis les regarderons aussi bien sûr
maxime qui se frottera à nice guéri dans
le tournoi de quinssaines
il aura réussi nemo contre caruana qui
sera certainement sympa à suivre donc je
vous laisse entre de bonnes mains en une
heure
je vous dis à très bientôt salut tout le
monde et merci d'avoir participé
ciao